when it comes to the ongoing anthology
series american horror story
the amount of twists and turns and time
traveling can get a little confusing
so we're here to help you make sense of
the entire american horror story
timeline
in the first season murder house we
learned that famous hollywood surgeon dr
charles montgomery built a classic los
angeles victorian mansion for his wife
nora while they were flush with
celebrity money but their fortune
quickly turned sour as charles's mental
illness and frankenstein complex
forced him to give basement abortions to
make ends meet the husband of one client
killed charles and norah's son in
retaliation cutting him up into pieces
charles stitched the boy back together
along with other people's parts
creating the monstrous infantata was it
this grotesque series of acts that
turned the montgomery house evil
or was the evil there all along this
question has yet to be answered but when
ben
vivien and violet harmon move into the
haunted mansion in 2011
it's been home to dozens of suspicious
deaths it's not long before the harmons
realize the ghosts of those people are
very much active within the house's
walls
including their housekeeper moira who
appears to ben as a seductive young
woman
and to vivian as a sad but helpful older
woman and as if that wasn't enough for
the poor harmons
constance tate and addie langdon are
nosy next door neighbors who constantly
appear in their house without invitation
and they only hint at the house's sordid
past without mentioning their own role
in it
plus tate is having therapy sessions
with ben and he and violet quietly begin
falling in love until a new series of
tragedies strike
ben has been unfaithful to vivian in the
past so when he shows up in a kinky
black rubber suit
vivian thinks he's trying to rekindle
the previous passion of their marriage
unfortunately it isn't been in the suit
the so-called rubber man
is actually tate langdon and worse the
harmons find out that tate is another of
the ghosts haunting the house
having killed himself on the property
after committing a mass shooting at
school
creepier still after getting it on with
a ghost vivian is suddenly pregnant with
twins
one of whom is decidedly not human i'm
sure you're aware
that these babies well rather one of
these babies has been developing
at a rapid rate the human child is still
born
and the other is revealed to be the
antichrist born from spirit and flesh
as prophesied by the psychic billy dean
howard the hits for the harmons don't
stop there
tate convinces violet to overdose on
sleeping pills so they can be together
forever
she and her parents don't realize she's
dead until she tries to escape murder
house and can't leave
we then learned that tate had hidden her
dead body underneath the house
sadly vivian dies during childbirth a
birth overseen by the ghost of charles
montgomery and she becomes a new
addition to the house
she tells ben to take the surviving
child and escape but the ghost of ben's
lover hayden kills him before he can
constance langdon takes the baby her
grandson instead
of course there are no happy endings
here as the first season of american
horror story ends three years later with
constance finding that her infant
grandson
has brutally killed his nanny and is
playing with her blood
set mostly in 1964 second season asylum
starts off with kit walker a man who's
kidnapped by aliens
after his wife and friend disappear kid
is imprisoned in briarcliff manor
an asylum for the criminally insane
where the staff are more disturbed than
their patients
headed by sister jude bryacliff is a
religious institution that handles its
vulnerable patients with more torture
than care
many of the patients aren't even the
criminals they've been painted to be
like peppa
a gentle non-verbal microcephalic woman
falsely accused of killing a baby as
well as promiscuous shelley whose
husband locked her up for cheating
on the medical staff for dr oliver
threadson in charge of counseling and
the sadistic dr arden a nazi doctor
who's performing horrific experiments on
brian cliff residence
meanwhile lana winters is a young gay
journalist who's been searching for her
big break
since lesbianism was considered a mental
illness at the time
lana gets herself committed to bryacliff
to produce an expose about its gruesome
ongoing events
she discovers that dr threats in his
bloody face a serial killer who's been
sexually assaulting
skinning and decapitating women after he
drugs and kidnaps her
however she's his only surviving victim
why
because she's pregnant with his baby
lana's story shocks america
after she exposes briarcliff and
threatened but years later
we find out that a bloody-faced copycat
who's been killing people at an
abandoned
briar cliff is lana and thretson's son
in the third season coven new orleans is
home to miss rober shows academy for
exceptional young ladies
a boarding school for witches run by the
supreme witch fiona goode
fiona has superpowers that she wields
for her own narcissistic ends rather
than the good of her community
unfortunately for fiona signs emerge
that a new supreme is on the rise as
fiona's health and looks begin failing
there can only be one supreme at a time
and the old supreme must die for the new
one to take the mantle the most
promising supreme candidates at robo
shows include timid zoe
confident queenie self-involved madison
montgomery
and sweet nan until misty day and almost
killed swamp witch with a penchant for
stevie nicks
takes sanctuary in the academy in the
meantime a group of witch hunters led by
hank fox husband of robo show
headmistress cordelia goode
is killing the new crop of witches on
their way to enroll at robo shows
old battle lines open anew when fiona
approaches her nemesis
voodoo queen marie laveau to find out
the secret of immortality so she can
remain supreme forever
when marie refuses fiona releases the
serial killer and torturer of slaves
delphine lalorie that marie had under
her spell wreaking new habit
as fiona's powers wane the witches
perform a series of tests called the
seven wonders to see who will ascend the
supreme throne
ultimately cordelia passes all seven
tests resurrecting zoe who died during
hers
misty day ends up trapped in purgatory
and madison's narcissism gets her sent
to hell
american horror story's fourth season
freak show keeps us in the south
in the town of jupiter florida during
elsa mars and her cabinet of curiosities
run a waning lakeside carnival in a
quiet town that loudly resents their
presence
the era of television is at its pinnacle
and people would rather sit at home
watching the screen than the antics of
freaks like lobster boy jimmy darling
ethel the bearded lady
strongman del toledo and his
hermaphrodite wife desiree dupree
to drum up sales elsa goes on a hunt for
new monsters to join her troop
finding the wholesome conjoined twins
bet and dot tattler however elsa's job
gets even harder when a serial killer
twisty the clown goes on a rampage
leading townsfolks to think the carnies
were responsible for the gruesome
murders
more threats to the freaks emerge with
shady stanley who's buying and killing
circus folks to sell their bodies to a
medical marvel museum
worse a rich psychopath named dandy mott
becomes fixated on bet and dot an
obsession that leads to him going on a
killing spree that leaves most of elsa's
performers dead
fortunately bet dot and jimmy escape and
get married
and for the first time the show makes
direct references to another american
horror story season as microcephalic
pepper from asylum
appears and reveals how her sister
killed her own malformed child
and framed pepper also we learned that
elsa's legs were amputated in a snuff
film by asylum's villainous nazi dr ardy
inspired by one of the most famous
serial killers in american history
hh homes the fifth season hotel takes
place in james march's hotel cortez in
downtown los angeles
in 1922 march builds his hotel with a
series of secret walls and basements so
he can kill and dispose of guests
without anyone noticing
march is also in love with a young
actress elizabeth whose affections
belong to movie star rudolph valentino
so naturally march disposes of valentino
but not before valentino turns elizabeth
into a vampire like him
after march's death he leaves the cortez
to elizabeth
now known as the countess who remains
its owner until 2015
when she's forced to sell to fashion
designer will drake
the countess plans to marry drake and
kill him to get her hotel back but the
cortez's ghost
as well as other angry parties like her
transgender bartender liz taylor throw
wrench after wrench into her bloody
plans
no pity party in my bar all the while
a serial killer is brutalizing people
based on violations of the ten
commandments
detective john lowe suspects the killer
is working from the hotel
because he's on the rocks with his wife
alex lowe rents a room to investigate
however over the course of the series we
learned that march had been searching
for a protege for years and by the end
of hotel
we discovered that detective lowe is the
ten commandments killer
alex has also become a vampire and the
countess entrusts
all the vampire children in the cortez
to her care we should also point out
that hotel has a reference to the first
season of american horror story as the
countess goes to the montgomery house to
get an abortion however the malformed
vamp baby lives
and she tends to it to this day playing
on its own narrative tricks
six season roanoke explores the
real-life disappearance of 16th century
north american settlers through an
in-show documentary entitled my roanoke
nightmare which centers around the
testimony of homeowners shelby and matt
miller who buy a rundown mansion in the
north carolina woods and experience
supernatural terrors they chalk it up to
the inbred polk family who previously
owned the house
matt's sister lee harris comes with her
young daughter flora to help out and
they all discover there are dark spirits
not just in the house but also in the
woods
and life in their fixer-upper becomes a
fight for survival
my roanoke nightmare is the show within
the show that explores the roanoke
events featuring the folks who lived it
from 2014 through 2016
along with reenactors to play shelby and
matt as well as matt's sister lee harris
the meta commentary goes even deeper
when my roanoke nightmare producers
decide to bring the real-life shelby and
company
along with the actors playing them back
to the mansion during the blood moon the
blood moon is the time when the ghosts
of the area come alive and perform a
series of violent rituals headed by the
first lady of roanoke
thomason white aka the butcher the
original supreme scothack
also manifests ultimately possessing lee
harris who proceeds to go on her
own killing spree to save her daughter
lee chooses to go with the roar no
ghosts and the historical mystery of the
area only becomes more enigmatic
american horror story seventh season
cult drops us into the suburb of
brookfield heights michigan
in the wake of donald trump's
inauguration in 2017.
ally and her wife ivy own a local
restaurant that's newly struggling
due to divisive political rhetoric
that's led to a rise in hate crimes
against marginalized people in their
town
as a result ally's childhood traumas are
so severely provoked that her phobia of
clowns emerges with a vengeance
as well as a serious paranoia that
someone's out to get her
ali is far from wrong a charismatic but
deeply bigoted and misogynistic man
named kai anderson feels empowered by
the new political regime and runs for
public office on an open platform of
hate
i said there is nothing more dangerous
in this world than a humiliated man
he's also the leader of a cult that has
been dressing up as clowns
and killing people around town but
because nobody but ally has witnessed
the clowns
these murders get chalked up to a
variety of other motives
ally's past mental health issues make
her easy to gaslight when her wife comes
out as one of kai's cult members but in
one of the more complex narrative
seasons with numerous plot lines woven
together it turns out that kai's sexist
platform
was orchestrated by valerie solanas and
her lover bibi
in order to blast women out of
complacency and into political rage
solanus famous for shooting andy warhol
is also revealed to be the infamous
zodiac killer who was never
caught after kai is killed ali runs for
senate and wins
ending the season with the suggestion
that she's become a new cult leader
herself
in the eighth season apocalypse we
learned that vivian harmon and tate
langdon's baby from murder house is
michael langdon and he's the antichrist
here to kickstart the end times but
first the hawthorne school for
exceptional young men the warlock
version of mishroboshow's academy in
coven mistakes him for the most powerful
warlock ever known
one that might be the first male to
ascend to supreme status
michael passes all of the seven wonders
and he even manages to rescue misty day
madison montgomery and queenie from
their purgatories in the years after
coven
queenie visited the hotel cortez and has
been trapped there ever since
the actual supreme cordelia goode is
doubtful about michael's powers but when
her own begin to wane
she wonders if it's true he's next in
line of succession
he is not and by the time the witches
figure it out michael has instigated
nuclear war on a devastated planet but
he was unable to kill
all the witches and now they're the only
ones who can stop him
cloaked under an identity spell in
outpost 3 the former side of hawthorne
school
the witch mallory is the up and coming
supreme whose powers almost match that
of michael's
she's able to travel through time to
2015 and kill michael before he properly
comes into his antichrist abilities
halting the apocalypse or so we think
apocalypse closes in an unspecified
present
where former outpost 3 members emily and
timothy meet
fall in love and have a baby like baby
michael at the end of murder house
their child also kills the nanny
suggesting that the birth of satan might
not have been halted at all
we also think it's necessary to
highlight a particular episode directed
by american horror story queen sarah
paulson where we are taken all the way
back to the beginning to fill in a
number of pending storylines
following the witch madison montgomery
and warlock behold shablee the episode
finds the montgomery house in a sad
state
upon discovering her grandson was the
antichrist constance langdon killed
herself there so she could be with all
the ghost children in the haunted
mansion
including the infantata monsta the
harmons have retreated to their own
corners with vivian avoiding ben at all
cost
and violet refusing to have anything to
do with tate langdon the boy she loved
but who assaulted and impregnated her
mom with the antichrist
thanks to madison and behold's meddling
they find out that the evil that had
possessed tate
transferred to michael langdon and
madison helps violet and tate reconcile
which is another strange and rare happy
ending in american horror story
madison also helps the housekeeper moira
who'd constance kill decades before
after moira had an affair with her
husband
find her bones and then be buried with
her beloved mother finally letting her
rest in peace
now that the witches owned the
montgomery house there should be no new
ghost created within its walls
as is the case with many time travel
narratives an entire plot arc can
sometimes get dismantled as the story
moves between different realities
and potentially parallel universes when
mallory uses her power to alter time
itself by going back to 2015 and killing
satan's son
it raises one big unanswered question
how could time travel affect the show's
timeline as it stands
well based on the years in which they
take place the present day events of
roaring oak and cult
might not have happened at all anymore
of course the histories of the original
supreme
thomas and the butcher the polk family
in real life matt and shelby buying the
mansion could be retained
as well as the flashbacks to valerie
solanus and andy warhol and colt
but what stands of the rest of these
seasons is unclear until we get more
information in future episodes
might the election results of cult even
shift in a world where a first
apocalypse was nearly averted
or since a new antichrist gets born
regardless will the timelines play out
similarly to how they already have
we can only hope new seasons will tell
in many ways the ninth season
1984 was something of a pallet cleanser
for fans of the show due to its
standalone nature as a mostly
straightforward slasher movie homage
following a group of familiar american
horror story faces
in new roles at camp redwood 1984 dove
big into 80s nostalgia through the
secrets of camp blood
and all of its many ghosts new and old
eagle-eyed fans spotted many references
in 1984 that called out or back to
previous seasons of the show
from small details like margaret booth
buying bridecliff mana from second
season asylum and the fact that mr
jingle's cabin in alaska is the same as
kit walkers and asylum
to massive thematic connections like
haunted places where the dead don't stay
dead
starting all the way back in the show's
opening season murder house
but arguably the biggest connection 1984
has to the bigger arc of the narrative
is its connection to satan and his
minions on earth a thread that thanks to
apocalypse
coven and hotel has become one of the
fundamental pillars of the entire
american horror story tapestry
in 1984 we once again meet the night
stalker richard ramirez
as he forges new deals with his master
lucifer as well as other dangerous
killer ghosts
because we don't exactly know how 1984
fits in with the changed world brought
about by apocalypse yet all we can do is
wait for future seasons of the anthology
to hopefully reveal more about the
larger picture
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one